Oh is there a better way to get to work
than by helicopter let me answer that
capital in a little the repercussions of
very changing the timeline span all
across the spectrum for all of our
characters Cisco I don't know you string
bean
mr. Ramon oh yes he's created an
alternate reality where Cisco is
actually cashed in on his talents Cisco
as a richest man in America offer than
20 mil Cisco's become the Sun on toast
billionaire that heads up this giant
tech company basically you know what
happens when you mess with a speedster
that that's what happens you get a
vibrating hand going right to your
ribcage no thanks my money needs me I
think underneath all of that there's
still a a pivotal core he might just
have a heart underneath deep down you
care about helping other people please
tell me more
hey youtubers it's Charlie so good news
flashes back this week we got a whole
bunch of new stuff about the first
couple of episodes we even learned
what's going on with Jessie quick so
this is gonna be a breakdown so let's
start with the Cisco stuff first because
he's got this Thomas Wayne vibe that
he's giving off only it's kind of like
in the direction of douche rather than
like hardcore like the difference
between Batman and Thomas Wayne is that
Thomas Wayne during the flashpoint
storyline does all the things that
morally Batman refuses to do like he
kills people he uses guns things that
the Bruce Wayne Batman of the main
timeline would never do so it's meant to
be a reflection of how wrong the
flashpoint timeline is like oh my god
this is terrible
everything's a nightmare we have to fix
this so this version of Cisco is just
meant to be like the complete opposite
of our main version of Cisco totally
selfish only cares about money doesn't
want to help anybody but himself so the
way Wally iris and Barry are looking at
him I mean one they're kind of laughing
at him like what the hell is going on
here but it looks like Iris doesn't know
him so it seems like this version of
Wally in this timeline has not been
working with Cisco because normally
you'd assume that the flash is working
with somebody to help him learn about
his powers bill technology for him so
there probably is at least one person
helping Wally out in this timeline
unless he completely built this suit by
himself but whatever ends up happening
we know that Barry
yoinks Caitlin from probably mercury
labs and tries to reassemble the team
and then later like we've seen Cisco
when they're filming later episodes with
his funny t-shirts on again so we know
we eventually get back to like the funny
Cisco that we know but like douche bags
Cisco makes the comment about messing
with speedsters like I don't want to
mess with speedsters you know what that
gets you a vibrating hand through your
chest just like he got killed by ego bar
Thawne and the alternate timeline during
season 1 so would it be crazy if this
version of Cisco also got killed by the
rival or even a of our thought again
because he has to escape at some point
so he can go off to legends of tomorrow
but whatever they end up doing with it
before they fix the timeline maybe he
writes the Thomas way note to his other
version of Cisco so we'll see we only
have a couple more days to wait like
literally the fly
is coming back on Tuesday it's gonna be
so awesome congratulations you've made
it all summer everything is back they've
been filming the hundredth episode still
like Stephen Amell posted this funny
tweet of how his schedule is going to
work this current week so like they're
still working on it so he's working on
all four different shows concurrently so
like one day he goes on to one show the
other day he goes on to another two
shows the other day he's back on his
show and that's just how they're filming
those four episodes this year so instead
of filming like an entire episode of
Supergirl then having everybody filmed
the episode of the flash then filmed the
episode of arrow they're all doing it
concurrently so it's actually really
cool
they usually film a lot of behind the
scenes stuff during this like the stuff
that the actors aren't posting on their
own social and they've been posting
pictures of themselves from behind the
scenes this is literally what I saw when
I opened my Twitter this morning it was
just like BAM staring at me in the face
so expect more of this kind of stuff for
at least the next week or so but all
this stuff is gonna be airing in early
December it's episode 8 of the flash and
arrow and episode 7 of Supergirl and
legends of tomorrow just because
Supergirl in legends of tomorrow started
shooting a week after these other shows
but we'll talk more about that when they
drop more information the other really
cool thing about the flash season 3 that
we learned is they released a
description for episode 3 and it teases
a speedster Jesse quick so we will see
full-on comic book costume Jesse quick
running with Speed Force
so the teaser is is that like the
villain of the episode the episode is
called magenta that's the name of the
rogue that we're gonna meet she's being
played by this girl here so already
you're like oh wow this is gonna be
pretty cool but then you find out that
earth to Harrison wells
and Jessie quick comeback so we know
that it's the earth 2 version from last
season don't know if they've been
changed by flashpoint but I'm assuming
that they actually fix flashpoint in
episode 2 so we're back to the regular
timeline and that's why it's earth -
Harrison wells and Jessie quick but they
come back in Harrison wells confides in
team flash and says Jessie quick has
Speed Force powers she's been saving
people on earth - I want you to tell her
to stop using them it's two days
like he's worried about her it's giving
me like this puberty type metaphor like
Jessie quick his daughter has started
like dating having sex with people and
he's afraid that she's going to get hurt
so he doesn't want her in harm's way
doesn't want her to be sexually active
as inactive with speedforce so we can
make all the Harrison Wells jokes when
we get to Episode three so that's a
couple weeks away but I don't know what
her costume is gonna look like if it's
gonna be the Liberty Bell costume the
blue or if it's gonna be the Jessie
quick costume where it's red and yellow
because she wore both versions of the
costume in the comic but I'm kind of
hoping that she wears the blue costume
just because we have so many red
costumes already that it would be nice
to have just like a little bit of
differentiation but let me know in the
comments which costume do you want
Jessie quick to wear now obviously it's
gonna look a little bit different from
the comic book costume but like if you
look at Wally's costume it's actually
pretty close to kid Flash's yellow
costume from the comics so whatever they
do with Jesse quick it'll probably be
pretty close to the comics but a new
round of the giveaway all you guys have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video we're
gonna have all kinds of DC stuff
dropping next week I'm still working on
Luke Cage videos so my next video for
that should post tomorrow there's some
really cool game of Thrones stuff that
I'm gonna post tonight and if you guys
didn't know Westworld is premiering on
Sunday that's on HBO it's like a sci-fi
series it's kind of like Game of Thrones
only with a more sci-fi slant it's like
their new big genre show that's gonna
air this fall so be sure to check that
out I will do a video for the first
episode we get hype everythings back so
just a reminder flash and arrow back
next week Supergirl and legends of
tomorrow are back the week after that
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that hardcore arrow
trailer again and you can click here for
my superhero Fight Club video thank you
so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight